hi I'm Erik Bosse and Game of Thrones
has given us a new look at a scene from
season 8 the final season coming this
April in folks this teaser took up five
seconds of HBO's 2019 promo
that is two full seconds longer than the
very first three-second clip that we got
a few months ago and at 24 frames per
second that's 120 separate photographs
is scrutinized for discreet wardrobe
choices and let's break it all down and
spoiler warning in case I get anything
too right ruin your life okay after a
shot from season 7 episode 4 there's
this overhead shot of a snow-covered
Winterfell you can see some encampments
outside the city walls now I'm not sure
if this is an old shot or if this is a
new shot from season 8 like I guess
these could be Dothraki camps I don't
see any of Danny's dragons though
whatever it is we move on to this
greeting between Sansa Stark and
Daenerys Targaryen now this looks like
it's taking place shortly after the shot
that we saw in the first teaser with
Sansa greeting John with some icy stare
at someone over his shoulder now we can
presume that someone is indeed Daenerys
but in this teaser her tone has
certainly softened Winterfell is you
okay so this thing will take place early
in episode 1 of the final season maybe
in the opening scene though I could also
see the season opening with a pre
credits teaser the way last season did
with Arya at the twins we know this from
an Entertainment Weekly set visit which
described the scene as full of callbacks
to the show's pilot episode and noticed
us dance is greeting Dany the same way
her father Ned Stark greeted King Robert
Baratheon 9 is I am not seeing you where
the hell have you been guarding the
north for you your grace
Winterfell is yours so by greeting Dany
adds your grace Sansa is recognizing her
as monarch not John who was kin to north
last time they were together since is
excepting for this moment at least that
John bent the knee to Dany pledging his
fealty to this Targaryen invader this is
a big deal and it's a surprising move by
Sansa because let's not forget the last
time she and John were together at
Winterfell she urged him not to visit
Dany
have you forgotten what happened to our
grandfather the Mad King invited him to
King's Landing and roasted him alive
she is here to reclaim the Iron Throne
and the Seven Kingdoms the North is one
of those Seven Kingdoms this isn't an
invitation it's a practice it as a Tris
Targaryen because Danny's crazy father
the Mad King murdered their grandfather
Rickard stark a move that led the North
to join Robert's rebellion to destroy
the Targaryen dynasty and the North has
always had a cold relationship with the
Targaryen sever since their ancestor
tauren Stark aka the king who knelt
surrendered independence to Aegon the
conquerer a move that cost torrents
reputation to the north even if it saved
them from inevitable destruction from a
gods dragon balerion so that distrust in
Sansa it's probably the same stance that
we saw in that frosty glare but between
then and now I'm assuming that John will
have told her something to reassure her
this dragon woman say me live up north
of the wall also she's me opti and I
whatever it was Santa's cool headedness
might be a tactic that she learned from
Petyr Baelish of all people I'm and she
just sent it to the death in the
previous episode thank you for all your
many lessons Lord Baelish I will never
forget them earlier in season seven
Littlefinger imparted upon Sansa one
very crucial lesson tried every battle
everywhere always in your mind everyone
is your enemy
everyone is your friend and that is
exactly what sense is doing with this
frenemy fighting the battle in her mind
realizing there's no sense and openly
dissing a conqueror with two dragons to
her face perhaps she's mentally aiming
your grace at the man standing beside
Danny now as always the subtle
expressions of other observers are also
revealing behind Sansa Brienne of Tarth
can be seen and her concern could
suggest she's anticipating conflict like
I really don't want to draw my sword I'm
a couple dragons
and John looks similarly uneasy but
somewhat relieved to see Sansa play nice
like have sisters in incestuous
girlfriends can be best friends right I
mean it's interesting to see which
escort Dany chooses upon her entrance to
Winterfell like notice how the hand of
the Queen
Tyrion Lannister is nowhere in sight
that's some wise diplomacy considering
the North's hatred and distrust of the
Lannister family instead joining her is
Jorah Mormont
son of the loyal northern house Mormont
currently led by young Lyanna Mormont
years ago remember Jorah was sentenced
to death by Sansa's father Ned for slave
trading which is legal in Westeros
stripping Jorah of his titles and
forcing him into exile but perhaps the
hope is that given house where montz
recent support of House Stark and jurors
service to John and his mission north of
the wall the complex of their father's
everything in the past
now notice Danny is wearing the same
white fur coat that we saw in episode 6
of last season Game of Thrones costume
designer Michelle Clapton said that
Danny's wardrobe in season 7 was
intended to reflect the look of her
brother Viserys whom she killed but she
wanted to reconnect with her Targaryen
family roots as she returned to their
ancestral home of Dragonstone and she
essentially fulfilled her brother's
dream of invading Westeros it's sweet
sort of and Danny switched from the
color black to the color white reflected
her heroic leap from black hat to white
hat into danger to aid another person
for the first time in her life in that
moment she became a warrior queen in the
chain that you see across her clothes
reflects that it's a silver chain with
three dragon heads forming the pin and
now there are some updates to her look
first you can now see what looks like a
Targaryen crimson scarf underneath that
white coat perhaps to bundle up from the
cold more maybe to cover up some nephew
nibbles yeah cribs all you want but you
know you should feel gross about that
now some are also looking at Daenerys
his hair we previously discussed how her
braid is a Dothraki Jayhawk
it's a braid that is only cut to the
warrior loses in battle an Easter hack
has grown longer and more sophisticated
throughout the seasons you can notice
now how Danny's hair has been partially
released to drape over her shoulders but
while we could read this as another
diplomatic tactic by Dany like a more
northern hairstyle to endear yourself to
the northerners or what some are
describing as a matronly look folks
let's remember Danny's hair looked this
way at the start of season 7 so chill
and for anyone who says they can see a
hint of a baby bump guys it's pretty
early like that incestuous both sexes
would have just happened a few weeks
earlier as John and Danny were in route
to Winterfell
granted the amount of time it takes to
travel across Westeros constantly
changes and Game of Thrones
what some characters crawling at glacial
paces others magically teleported
hundreds of miles it's Dainius Lee all
depending on what the seasons narrative
structure requires so sure maybe the
flight time between white Harbor and
Winterfell
is a trimester and a half I say to send
a call
but here's my question for you
considering Daenerys at the end of
season seven was more or less a mother
losing her child the dragon bazarian
do you think the final season will
repeat this tragedy with Dany losing her
human child or reverse it with a dream
of spring with the birth of a healthy
child that replaces the one she lost
comment down below with your thoughts
and follow the new rock stars on Twitter
at new rock stars follow me on twitter
and instagram at a vas and subscribe to
new rock stars 4k medoras updates and
breakdowns because guys it's gonna be a
very big year for thrones I'm psyched to
be talking about it again my life just
isn't complete without people tweeting
me that the name is pronounced or yeah
and not Arya look in America it's Arya
in her me own and gal get [ __ ] up are
you hearing me friend